solidarité à présent parcourir 3000 km à
pied à travers la france est le défi que
s'est lancé cyril maurice une course
courageuse qui réalise au profit de
l'association rêves présent dans les
yvelines depuis quatre ans cette
association a déjà réalisé sans rêves
d'enfants gravement malades à l'hôpital
new de versailles comme rencontre un
sportif assister à un spectacle ou
encore visiter disneyland paris
alors monsieur cyril maurice est parti
de chez lui le début début avril sa
course comprend sans étape avec une
moyenne de 40 km par jour
aujourd'hui il s'est arrêté place
d'armes à versailles qu'est ce qui la
pousse à réaliser une telle course que
représente l'association rêves les
réponses au micro de fanny bourdillon à
l'époque mon fils était malade
donc il s'est fait opérer il ya trois
ans maintenant ça va mieux et donc la
rencontre avec d'autres parents et voir
voilà tout c'est tout c'est y qui m'a
vraiment marqué donc c'était un des
premiers facteurs on va dire à dessiner
ce projet et par la suite moi j'ai eu un
petit accident sportif dont tu me suis
reconverti dans la course à pied et donc
je me suis associé au ici avec un papa
qui a une petite fille qu'elle leucémie
justement est donc au fur et à mesure
j'ai augmenté mes km justement pour
atteindre vraiment la discipline battu
marathon et donc je voulais vraiment
alliés voilà c'est ce côté humain et
sportif et c'est comme ça que le projet
s'est dessinée l'association rêves
elle existe depuis 1994 elle réalise le
rêve des enfants très gravement malades
dont le pronostic vital est engagé
aujourd'hui elles et réparties dans
toute la france il ya 38 délégations qui
sont implantées et il ya 700 bénévoles
qui oeuvrent tous les jours pour pouvoir
récolter des fonds et permettre donc les
rêves de ses enfants